nom de zeus martin les lego font du
cinéma
retour vers le futur le film de robert
zemeckis est l'un des nombreux diorama
de l'exposition signer en briques pour
son exposition de fin d'année versailles
a fait appel à des associations pour les
lego c'est un terme assez facile dans le
sens où c'est assez large
il ya quand même beaucoup de dérives et
film
deux licences qui sont axées cinéma donc
on peut arriver à faire quelque chose de
relativement simple faut imaginer que le
star wars ça fait à peu près on va dire
un an qui travaillent dessus et ça fait
quasiment six mois qu'il installait en
morceaux dans le salon d'un des
adhérents ils sont trois à le créer des
films cultes pour les parents des films
jeunesse pour les enfants autour des
dioramas des photos de l'artiste sam
sophie de quoi ravir les visiteurs
j'aime bien celle d'harry potter est
celle de star wars
si génial on a vraiment envie d'avoir
ces légaux et de les construire
il ya plein de créativité c'est très
beau j'aime beaucoup ça me donne envie
de construire des petits ego et à saman
plein d'idées à des constructions près
de 800 mille pièces et petites briques
pour plonger au coeur du 7e art et parce
que les maquettistes aime bien jouer
avec le public
à vous de trouver les intrus dans chaque
drame à